you were doing career salary for Elton
Brand who's now the 76ers Jam I went one
sixty four five for a career salary
Elton Brand Paul did you have the
numbers I do okay there in time to play
career salary here's your host Paul
Allen bran with Anna Clipper Sixers a
few other teams a bunch of all-star
games a lot of twenty and ten seasons
Elton Brand career salary the most you
ever made in one season with 17 mil okay
with the Sixers no wonder you're so fond
of 169 million dollars brain okay good
guess and I didn't go over so I I don't
know what I win I think I win an
opportunity to talk to Elton Brand the
76ers gee I'm two-time all-star and
former Co Rookie of the Year with Stevie
franchise I believe Elton good to talk
to you congratulations hey thank you
really
what do you have your career salary out
wow it must be nice if you may stop
counting all right how did you end up
with the job so they basically started a
tournament and they had some outside
external candidates that they were
looking at and then they said well the
internal group has been doing this for
the last five months each one of you
will be entered in the tournament so
let's see what you have and that's how
it started
how did you win the job I was prepared I
used my relationships I called owners or
call GM's not just to prepare for the
for the interview but also just to
prepare if I got the job and then
in-house with my group they said look
we've been doing this for five months
and each of them said we would like you
to lead in some type of capacity which
was like okay now I have to step up not
only for the organization but my group
that we've been doing this for the last
five months so if they feel it should be
me it wasn't any internal bickering like
of course they're gonna interview but
when they were asked in their interview
at least they told me they said I should
be
in the lead role you didn't want a coach
why why run a team or the front office
yeah I didn't want a coach you know I've
been around some coaches some coach of
the years and possibly had to do with
coaches not doing so well but I I just a
coaching thing wasn't for me
imagine executive and being on this side
is what I would I look to do you talked
to Coach K about this oh absolutely
just when it was you know in the infant
stages like hey coach I could possibly
possibly go interview for this job what
do you think and he says you know go for
it it's a long way from Peekskill that's
why grew up in New York he's become
recruit me there 20 plus years ago but
he said he'll be great at it go for it
who was your football team growing up in
Peekskill I didn't really have a
football team and I kind of rooted for
best notes they made it to the Super
Bowls like back to back to back that
that thermode team and kelly yes I wrote
it for them but you weren't a football
fan no good I try to play Pop Warner and
I was too heavy so we couldn't you know
you had to be I think 110 or less I was
the age but I was too heavy to play Pop
Warner so I was never into football like
watching the NFL a lot so you were not
did lunch I was excited about I enjoyed
it but I didn't watch a lot so you were
too big to play Pop Warner yeah I can
understand that if they had a slam dunk
contest for fun office personnel in the
NBA right now would be the favorite oh
you do who would be your who would be
the your best Challenger yeah that's
what I was thinking I mean I don't know
if Shaun Marx could still get out yeah I
mean yeah it's not too many that I think
it could get above the rim I still can
get the finger tips and all that like I
think I could to get a few dunks in well
you you should still be able to dunk
Elton you can stay okay I don't think
Danny Ainge can dunk or
polenka Ernie Grunfeld
yeah you might win you might be the only
guy out there everybody else is shooting
layups and you're you'll be out there
and make one dunk and you'd win the slam
dunk contest yeah that's terrible to
watch but it's yeah I can do it for sure
he's Elton Brand these 76ers GM you
talked to marquel Foltz yes would you
talk to him about this is encouraging
summer you know he's been working
tirelessly also spoke so many times of
the pressures of being a number one pick
in just a long game just take every day
at a time it's not about how you
progressing right now in this moment
just keep getting better and hopefully
we'll look back and and you will develop
to the player that are deserving of the
number one pick Jim or lose your shot
yeah I'm probably yeah probably that for
sure for sure and what you do well me
personally I just just kept working
worked at it worked at it push myself
stayed away from it got away from
basketball for a while just does not
have to not even think about it what is
the so what's the process now in
Philadelphia it is the old process
processed and we move on to something
else the process isn't processed still
have more to do you know we are of
course trying to improve upon and
develop our young nucleus you know Ben
and Joe there was their first playoff
experience they're gonna get much better
by leaps and bounds teams today
especially in this game needs three or
maybe even four superstars or star
players star type player star level
players hopefully we have that in-house
and make we can develop if not they have
to be ready for free agency we have to
be ready for you know trade so but yeah
that the process hasn't been processed
yet who's the best teammate you ever had
that's varies Andre Godiva was a great
teammate Dirk Nowitzki in Dallas why'd
you laugh these because these are guys
that could still play and like Dirk and
I would get into it about defense and
other stuff but definitely a great
teammate but like when I came into the
league Randy brown Dickie Simpkins guys
like that were just special and they
helped create my leadership in the
locker room kind of persona because I
saw from those guys they weren't
competing with you they really generally
wanted you to succeed you missed out on
playing with Jordan didn't you yep yep
well it was it one season that you
missed out yes champions then there was
the year that they were not the
champions and not so well and then they
drafted me so Mike came back and played
with the Wizards I played against them a
few times when he was I think 40 how did
he do in 40 minutes on trashing 40 40 he
could still play very well at 40 he was
if you faced him bead in your prime how
would you do first of all yeah I
wouldn't want to face him like I faced
him when I came back to be around the
Sixers I was one of the first NBA type
bodies to play against him when he was
coming from rehabbing and stuff like
that so that's why we have a special
bond I was before he played a game a
preseason game I was that punching bag
and I told people that he was special
like ultimately like kind of things all
times like special just his mentality
his touch oh yeah like I'm guarding them
and I've got his Shack and afterwards I
felt very similar I was so all over my
body like I couldn't move he was amazing
and then he had enough handle and he has
more handle now he's shooting threes and
making some now he makes a lot more this
is two seasons ago but it was he's
incredible and he's gonna
and he loves basketball he wants to
improve and he wants to be the best so
you know all those intangibles combined
he's a special great player yeah that
description of guarding Shaq because
it's something that we would never be
able to do I just can't imagine he's the
biggest human being it feels like on the
planet him and Yao Ming hey what's that
first time like when all of a sudden you
know Shaq it's in the low post I mean
it's just like what am I gonna do it I'm
gonna just follow social media I wasn't
as big as it is now so getting dunked on
you know wasn't as embarrassing but
there was nothing you could do once he
got to that low post and it's similar to
you know how Jowell is what it what did
Shaq way back then cuz you were what -
60 - 65 - 65 I know you'd have to ask
big fella he it kind of fluctuating I it
was three something at times I'm not
sure there's always a 3 in front of that
when Shaq though I would think so but he
weighed a lot and he was but it's not
just so there's big guys maybe not as
big as shocking yeah but there's big
guys but they don't know how to play and
use it like he was mobile with all that
like he knew he had touch like he had
surprisingly he had speed so it was just
yeah he just had the whole package well
good luck I'm happy for you
Elton Brand the 76ers general manager is
a nice little ring to it and maybe it
has a different kind of ring to it down
the road but Elton good to visit with
you again and thanks for joining us it's
Elton Brand the pride of Peekskill New
York and Col rocky of the year with
Steve Francis Stevie francese there and
we go back a long way without Brent for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
you
[Music]